you know sometimes i look at the
scammers these days and i wonder could
we do better than this
i mean is this the best the scammers
have to offer
right here 6k andrew on tick tock
you know waving 30k around as if
anyone's gonna believe that he actually
makes that
is this really what we have is this the
best
20 20 can muster one year ago i dropped
out of high school to pursue
he's misspelled it e-commerce and
i think he needs to go back to high
school oh people said it was a bad
decision but i ended up making 100k in
my first year
okay will you think 100 profit no 100k
in sales
which means probably like 15k in profit
so he's like you guys think i'm an idiot
for dropping out of high school but i
made 15k last year
uh yeah we think you're dumb but my
point is
this is the kind of stuff that it gets
sent all the time
and i want to tell you there was an age
of scammer where people had class
i feel like it's like when the joker
says you know we need a better class of
criminal
this town that deserves a better class
hey
you guys aren't doing enough it's hard
to even want to respond to this stuff
honestly i don't even know how to get
out of bed in the morning when i look at
the stuff but let me tell you
in the 90s things were done very
differently
just compare and contrast this with this
ladies and gentlemen
how to get a second paycheck hawaiian
style this is from the 90s
but it hits different trust me watch and
learn boys
hawaii one of the most beautiful places
on earth
wow the production value the hired
actresses in the back walking
conveniently right next to this guy
my name is michael flynn and i'm here on
the beautiful island of maui
i've got a question for you right now
how would you like to be in hawaii
i would michael i would like that very
much enjoying the good life
and earning even more money than you do
right now at home when you're slaving
away at your regular
job michael you've got my interest okay
because i am slaving away here making
youtube videos the people at home don't
know this is the hardest job in the
world
very tough so i'm ready michael my
body's ready for whatever you have for
me
you've went to hawaii for me so i owe it
to you to watch this
in effect how would you like to get a
second paycheck
hawaiian style doesn't sound too bad
already b-roll on point look
guys remember remember what you could be
having you could be out of this guy
or you have this i think the answer's
clear
just imagine hawaii the land of
enchantment and magic
the waterfalls the land of volcanoes the
volcanoes
luaus and hula dancers tropical
rainforests
and the most beautiful beaches in the
world
this is another reason the 90s
infomercials just hit different
you had tom vu with his babes back in
the day calling them waterfalls
watching the waterfall in the front the
waterfall in the back
the pool looked like the lake waterfall
inside the house now we got the beaches
and the most beautiful beaches in the
world guys
the 90s infomercials next level okay
they knew how to play you subtly your
psychology right
hawaii where you can be skin diving in
the morning
parasailing after lunch shopping in
mid-afternoon
sipping a mai tai at sunset and yet all
the while
you're making more money than you ever
dreamed of
see look we already know it's a scam
right
but i'm there mentally i'm in hawaii
i've got the beaches
i've got the tropical rain forests i've
got it all even though i know it's a
scam
that's what made the 90s different if
you think that's impossible you're in
for a surprise
because in the next 30 minutes you're
going to meet a man who does all of that
okay let's skip forward and meet the man
all right this is the real man of the
hour that's right he has an intro man
the michael
he doesn't really matter this is the guy
that matters this is gary cochran
anything you ever dreamed possible and
you can do it with a very simple
business called
direct marketing 200 billion a year
industry
that's a figure most of us can't
comprehend can you even imagine
what 200 billion dollars looks like
george go ahead and bring them in
just are they bringing in 200 billion
dollars what's the wheelbarrow about
what are these men doing stay seated in
your seats these guys do not have a
great sense of humor
now last year hey
mr beast calm down this is what i'm
talking about
listen you can either have tiny tim over
here
or you can have the cochrane okay look
at this guy
that's a wheelbarrow full of cash
actually it's not one it's not two
it's three here over 92 million of it
for
us ordered by either mail or phone
six wheelbarrows of cash that's how much
i have right here on the stage
380 000 that's what's earned in direct
marketing
every minute now who would like some of
this cash
if i gave you some what would you do
with it what would you do with it
he's doing a genius move right now i'm
gonna tell you what it is in a second
but watch what he does
so first he primes people with the 20
i'll give you 20
what would you do with it you'd go out
to dinner here's 20
enjoy yourself but there's not enough to
take two what would you do with it
you have a need for a medical builder so
he's pulling the allen before it was
cool he gives it out to a bunch of
people and then
he takes it up a notch right yes right
there
you'd go surfing twenty dollars we'll
rent you something all right
now i'm not done i still have right here
i have some hundred dollar bills who
no no this is where the great pitch
starts guys he upset
a hundred dollars now you're primed to
think he's gonna give you a hundred
dollars
watch this wait just a second i've got
100 200
18 19 24 25
100 bills who wants one of these
guess what before i'm done today i'm
going to give 25 of you one of these 100
bills watch this guys this is genius
this is innovation okay watch and if
you're watching at home i'm going to
give you exactly the same opportunity
sleazebag scammer 100
kind of brilliant what he's about to do
when you get that payment you are going
to keep your portion of the payment and
you will keep it you will send the
balance of the payment
onto the producer of the product who
will ship that product directly to the
consumer
do you understand what drop shipping is
this is drop shipping oh i finally
understand
this guy's doing drop shipping scamming
before was cool right now
everybody has a drop shipping course
this guy hey back in the 90s
the innovation now you're asking
yourself what about the 100
stephen what happened what happened to
the 2500
he was gonna give away well let's find
out because this is this is next level
okay
i still have right here 25
100 bills who wants one of these but let
me ask you
if i people literally sat through this
whole presentation to get this money
gave you one
who would use it to invest in themselves
and get this course of materials
and get started today could i see your
hands that's exactly what i'm going to
do you come with me
and i will pay the first hundred dollars
of the cost of your program
wait a minute you're not giving the
money
you said you're giving people money but
only if they pay you
for your course which is 250 bucks so
so you're just doing a sale but think
about that
he had him wait the entire time
everyone's paying attention they think
there's going to be a quiz at the end
they think they're going to get 100 free
bucks
no you have to pay 250 bucks to get 100
bucks
so that your entire cost is only 149
dollars brian that's for this one right
here that's for this one right here
and for those of you at home you do not
have an opportunity to be at this
seminar
but i will do exactly the same thing for
you i will pay the first hundred dollars
of the cost of this program
you know guys i literally never fall for
this stuff but a hundred dollars
please stay on the line to continue i
honestly thought that this number would
be disconnected for sure
are you serious your call is important
to us please hold for the next available
specialist
by the way while we're waiting this is
one of the things i saw in the comment
section of this video
hilariously four months ago in a video
with 1900 people
i'm one of the 1900 people guys due to
overwhelming response all of our
representatives are assisting other
callers
please continue to hold for the next
available representative the
overwhelming response of people who are
still watching
gary cochran oh yeah it's a big
big slam pajama hit boys you know the
90s infomercials they're still
crushing sales calls okay
i'm pissed gary now i'm pissed due to
overwhelming response
all of our representatives are assisting
other callers please continue to hold
for the next available representative
i can't take it anymore i'm sorry i'm
sorry gary i tried
but interesting enough this seminar
which is still apparently selling tons
of copies
didn't last very long in 1991 they got
accused of operating a scam
for selling their instructive videotapes
because they didn't
actually ship out the products see gary
cochran owned this company called
american business seminars
and they raised thousand dollars by
accepting money for these tapes
but they failed to deliver the tapes and
they didn't provide refunds
so then what does gary do gary's in a
pinch well he decides to file for
bankruptcy
now the funny thing is i tried to look
up more about gary cochran there isn't
much available
but i did find you guys because i want
to close the story up i wanted to find
you the truth
about this 90s infomercial pioneer
i wanted to know what happened to him
right so i found an old newspaper
clipping this is literally from
1991 and basically they repeat the fact
that he's filing chapter 11 bankruptcy
so he looks like
his company was failing at the same time
in an affidavit filed
october 25th and this this paper came
out on november 2nd
it says that cochran was receiving a
salary of 700 000
per month while his wife made a hundred
thousand dollars a month
classic pay gap ladies and gentlemen but
it looks like the end of gary cochran
wasn't pretty
i don't know honestly you can't find
much online about him
but i thought this is an interesting
look at the scammers of
old we think of this as a new thing on
the internet
but the truth is scams like this are as
old as time right they were done in the
90s they were done even before that
with chain letters guys this is nothing
new but you got to educate yourself you
got to see through this stuff
but frankly i really do think it's
easier than ever because people like
this
uh it's disappointing they don't have
the class they don't have
the production value of the stuff back
in the day
and um honestly i think it's an
opportunity for people now because i
think it's easier than ever to see
through these guys
because they don't have the showmanship
the presentation skills back in the day
because
like look dude you look at the stuff
back in the day you almost want to buy
it
you almost want to go get a wheelbarrow
of cash yourself but nowadays you have
people like this and it's like oh yeah i
know this guy's scamming me of course
anyways guys
that's the video i hope you enjoyed a
look back if you like content like this
let me know we'll keep making them
all right thanks for watching and don't
forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
when you burn through your plastic